PROFESSOR: How
you feeling, Paul?
PAUL FOLINO: I'm
feeling well, thank you.
PROFESSOR: How does it feel to
be finished with this class?
PAUL FOLINO: It's bittersweet.
It's a little bit of a relief,
but I definitely learned a lot.
PROFESSOR: What was the
most unexpected thing
that you learned in this class?
PAUL FOLINO: I
guess how much audio
is important to making a video
instead of the actual video.
I mean, the video
is important too.
PROFESSOR: Do you think
that there is anything
that you learned in
this class that you
would apply to stuff outside
the video or anything moving
forward?
PAUL FOLINO: Yeah, definitely.
I learned how to
communicate better.
So I think I'd be
able to explain
things that are
a little bit more
technical in a simplistic way.
PROFESSOR: What was
the most helpful thing
that happened in class?
PAUL FOLINO: I'd have to
say working with the groups
and having the feedback
from multiple people.
I think that was a
good method to hone
in on the script and the video.
So all the feedbacks
was spot on too.
PROFESSOR: What about
the hardest thing?
So maybe the hardest assignment?
PAUL FOLINO: I think the hardest
part of it was taking a script
and trying to translate it
into different camera shots
and angles and how
many times to change
an angle and all that stuff.
It's kind of hard to do
that, so that took a while.
PROFESSOR: What was it
like being on camera?
PAUL FOLINO: It was
nerve-wracking at first.
I think I was more nervous
being on camera by myself,
shooting at home.
PROFESSOR: Really?
PAUL FOLINO: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Because I
was going to say you
sound very natural right now.
PAUL FOLINO: It might have
just been beaten out of me.
PROFESSOR: How would you
explain this class to someone
who's never taken it before?
PAUL FOLINO: It's a--
that's a tough one.
PROFESSOR: Or who
should take this class?
PAUL FOLINO: I think
anyone who wants to-- I
wouldn't even say anything to
do with videography or anything
like that.
It's just if you
want to learn how
to describe things in a clear
way and be-- I don't know.
That's all I'd say.
There's definitely a big
technical aspect to it,
but I'd say that's kind
of just a byproduct
of the actual learning.
PROFESSOR: Thank
you for your time.
PROFESSOR: You're welcome.
PROFESSOR: Next question.
PROFESSOR: Are you nervous?
Are you excited?
How do you feel about the--
PAUL FOLINO: I'm excited
to see everyone's videos.